[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
happy three by tuesday welcome to the
group chat live in the blitz report app
presented by fandor
we're going to do our best to give you a
combined russell westbrook triple double
aaron dolan's going to give you points
greg ivory's going to assist in your
wardrobe
and i'm going to grab some rebounds and
keep it moving my name is cabbie
richards our you are getting
premier betting expertise from aaron
dolan from fanduel
and the other babyface assassin from the
bay area
gaelia is mr g
craig ivory back in december absolutely
nobody would have predicted that
the new york knicks would be in the
playoffs and the defending nba champions
the los angeles lakers would be
agonizing in a play internally
but here we are everybody's got a
prediction but this is why we played the
game
tonight we're asking you who will score
more points head-to-head
julius randle of the new york knicks or
anthony davis of the los
angeles lakers to quote the great kobe
bean bryant
anthony davis put on his big boy pants
against the phoenix suns on sunday
and he carried that team so uh g-money
are we getting some east coast love in
the comments or some west coast love in
the comments
for this specific matchup cabbie let me
talk to him hey people in the comments
everybody in the comments i either need
east coast west coast love y'all know
the west coast is the best coaster
i don't know if i agree with that i just
let that be known i mean seriously let
that be
known cabbie you're not even from the
east coast bro
what's going on you're from up north
yeah yeah toronto is east
no i'm just messing with you i'm just
messaging but uh aaron we know you're
from
philly you know you're from philly are
you leaning east coast
in julius randle or are you uh rocking
with the best side the west side in a.d
so i'm actually going with anthony davis
he's gonna have to step up of course
with lebron james ruled out for this
game i was originally going with julius
randle but of course this was before
lebron i figured he would take some
points away from a.d
but randall's been quiet lately 14
points against the clippers 24 against
the suns 14 against the nuggets in the
knicks last three games
a.d meanwhile finally finding his stride
since that injury
again dominant back-to-back performance
42 points against the sun's 36
against portland so i'm riding with a.d
there was like 45 check marks in that
answer aaron
well done uh both defenses
yeah no no doubt both defenses are
identical
and uh both frank vogel and tom
thibodeau are great tacticians
and a hallmark of julius randle's game
is scoring in isolation
loves that the lucky lefty loves that
iso he scored the second most points in
isolation
um and he flirts with a triple-double
most games but
who on the new york knicks is gonna
guard a resurging
anthony davis you know what i mean like
he he feels the pressure of the moment
there's no lebron james tonight so i
think that anthony davis is going to
deliver
another 30 point performance give me a d
tonight against the knicks in that
head-to-head matchup
um g-money where's the audience east
coast
west coast what we got for tonight
cabbie aaron and people that are new to
the show
this right here it's called the handy
dandy ipad and this
is where you guys will be winning your
hoodies cabbie aaron i
am in the comments uh starting it off i
got
ange three two two uh
he said yes sirsky what's goodie facts
martin best coast they're talking about
the east coast yeah we're talking about
uh uh julius randle uh unfortunately
you're talking about the wrong coast but
fortunately you are walking away with a
hoodie
and three two two shouts out to you i
got uh
i got hold on these are just moving so
fast
these are just moving so fast i got uh
martin martin levinson saying
east coast rocking with uh he's rocking
with julius randle the east coast i
don't know man i don't know what's going
on uh
i don't really see too many west coast
okay last one classic man stephen
west coast yes sir west coast yes sir
shouts out to you classic man steven you
are walking away with hoodie uh-oh the
candy dandy what about you what about
you are you leaning east west coast with
a.d
are you leading the east coast with
julius randle
okay i'm west
i'm west i'm west to the to the death of
me but on this
on this on this occasion i'm going to
rock with julius reynold and the plus
money here
uh he's been bawling he has been
absolutely bawling this year
uh but my reasoning is i've been
watching the knicks lately and i see the
ball in his hands
almost on every possession i'll take my
chances there with the plus money
ball and julius randle's hands almost on
every possession i mean the guys
averaging 23 and 10
he's been off been slow recently he's
been slow as far as in scoring points
but uh his coach his coach gave him a
little pick up to the media today
uh he gave him a little confidence so
i'm uh i'm rocking with julius randle in
this plus money he's also probably gonna
play
like 45 minutes tom thibodeau is just he
like who runs his players to the ground
but listen hey don't sleep on derrick
rose and rj barrett as also
also carry that load so i think aaron
you and i with the a.d pick is
it looks good uh as the great one once
said you miss 100
of the shots that you don't think the
one that you don't take
the one thing about the 3x2 that is in
common with the great wayne gretzky
is that it's the greatest bet in the
game today is three by tuesday and the
question is
will there be two three-pointers made in
the first three minutes of the game
last week we took the three by two in
brooklyn versus dallas and it cashed
like that let's take a look
look at this ball movement this is just
beautiful and the best shooter
right away joe harris money
love that starting lineup and thank you
josh richardson
on the wing
legitimately the fastest this this bet
is ever cash the first
the first two shots of the game were
three-pointers ah
count that easy money uh today we posted
that was easy cabbie no doubt hey hey i
just got
my bad my bad we were on the live when
this happened we were on the live and it
hit like within the minute bro we were
all juiced on live it was lit
make sure you guys tap into the live
today uh we're going to decide what game
we're riding with but tap into the live
today was all type of vibes bro
3x2 hit in less than a minute i don't
think you guys understand that that's
like legendary right yeah
did you run down the street we got our
money real quick did you run down the
street
no no no we we now we we we're acting
like we've been there before
we're acting like we've been oh so
you're you're barry sanders handing the
touchdown
the football back to the referee because
barry sanders like i've been here 150
times
um exactly so so today we posted a poll
on twitter
which two will cash tonight miami versus
boston
lakers versus the knicks there are the
odds
let us please see the results whoa
uh this has never happened before 50 50
even split
east coast west coast 50 oh my
i don't even i don't even know what to
do right so so in this
situation you've never been here before
so craig um who does the army think
is going to cash this bet like duncan
robinson
and jason tatum in the east coast game
or
or or uh julius randle and kyle kuzma
in the late game on tnt what do they
think uh
cabbie i have no idea but let me ask
them but we're gonna get creative with
this one i need east coast
or west coast gifts in the comments
right now
you guys give me gifts east coast west
coast depending on which game you're
riding with obviously miami boston is
the east coast
new york la is the west coast uh you
guys let me know which way are you guys
riding that's it right now but aaron so
what do you what what kits we need like
yeah yeah you see what was that
wait what what gifts the game's in la
games enough i know but like do
you want to see the baby my south beach
miami do you want to see like
leprechauns from
the boston celtics logo that's a good
one
we're shamrocks we're gonna leave i love
your examples cabbie
we're just to leave it up to the people
because it's going to get so creative
fair enough if they're going to get so
creative uh aaron yeah
aaron talk to me which 3x2 do you
think will catch tonight uh is it miami
boston or is it new york l.a sticking
with the east coast game miami celtics
for this three by two to cash duncan
robinson
shooting 40 percent from the three-point
line kendrick nunn 38
from beyond the ark plus jason tatum
kemba walker averaging
three three-pointers made per game so i
think they could come out and start
shooting
right away and have this cash i want to
see some dj
khaled some jimmy butler no dj khaled or
rick ross
gifts in the vibe like let's we're we're
taking this
i mean the game isn't in south beach but
it's miami boston for me
um no sad news coming out of boston that
that jaylen brown's
season is over with a wrist injury he
also had an ankle injury
so that void that product the void in
production is going to have to be filled
in part by evan fournier and marcus
smart and since the celtics were molly
waft on their
home court in the first half by miami in
the last game
79 points in two quarters i think that
celtics play with some urgency
so that's marcus smart kemba walker
evan fournier those guys will get it
done for boston and
on the other side if we get a little
kendrick none three-pointer or a duncan
robinson
three-pointer this three by two is gonna
cash so give me
give me miami boston uh and definitely
give me some
some dj khaled uh gifts in the comments
um
g-money yeah cabbie they got so creative
in the comments it's like super funny i
got ryan ray
i mean he got the dj kelly uh gif we all
know dj khaled's from the east coast
uh and from miami so therefore shout out
to you he's rocking with
you guys pick miami versus boston i also
see uh rick ross
my guy shaquille oatmeal shout out to
you shaquille
we got rick ross miami's finest in the
comments that's an immediate follow-up
for me immediate follow-up shaquille
oatmeal thank you
shaquille oatmeal cabbie it is lit it is
so lit
two man's picks two men's picks i don't
know
that's will smith it's will smith uh in
the gifts oh
he's pulling up ladies yeah yeah that's
a good will smith uh
they're getting real creative cabbie i
got palm trees bay area tabs with the
palm trees
palm trees la palm trees uh
they're all over the place in the
comments cabbie it looks like
which game wait which game do you want
like the the the twitter audiences
is locked 50 50. the the comment section
seems more east coast and west coast but
what do you personally
which game do you personally want to
lock into you money
it hurts me to say that but cabbie with
that being said i think i'm gonna rock
with this east coast game
as well miami versus boston
yeah we're all in agreement on this one
let me just name some uh
players that are gonna be on the court
uh
during this during this game uh duncan
robinson uh tyler hero will be on the
court
uh we got jason tatum we got uh
who else marcus spark kimball walker uh
three-point shooters i can keep going if
you want me to gabby like
kendrick nunn um i'm glad you didn't say
jimmy butler maybe corn dragon
the dragon jimmy butler jimmy
butler you can't you can't say dory but
you can't say the dragon the dragon
comes off the bench that's too
like you never like
but you never know what if something
happens early
fine what if someone come on okay it's
vibes bro
bad bod all right listen to chatbot for
good vibes go
make sure you check the br betting
socials uh to get the link to the 3x2
from fanduel
one of the benefits surrounding the
drama of the playing tournament
this season is that we haven't heard the
phrase load management
all to be and that's really because 20
teams are
vying for either playoff seeding or the
play-in tournament
if the strategy to reduce tanking has
worked even though
lebron james and luka doncic aren't fans
of
of the format but 20 fan bases
are fans of the play in tournament
format let's take a look at the latest
odds
for these five teams to make the
playoffs the charlotte hornets
golden state warriors san antonio spurs
uh
the wizards and the pacers i don't know
why i jumped over the pacers
in the middle there de monte sabonis
it's like what about us i'm like no
you're right
malcolm brogdon i see you i see you
fellas um
the leader right here is the golden
state warriors at -110 and the longest
odds are the san antonio spurs
who seem to be crumbling right now um g
money a month ago luca doncic was quoted
as saying and i
quote i don't understand the idea of the
playing tournament you play 72 games to
get into the playoffs
then maybe you lose two games in a row
and you're out of the playoffs i don't
see the point of that
so g-money where does the audience stand
and where do you stand on the playing
game
cabbie i'll get to where i stand a
little bit later uh
but let me ask the let me ask the
audience let me ask you guys hey hey
guys
are playing games a good idea do you
guys think that
this is a good idea i know braun said
that somebody needs to be fired for
these playoff playing games
and i know seth like yeah yeah and then
i know steph like kind of clapped back
at a question like if you guys played
the lakers he kind of made made fun of
it because
i don't think 30 is worried about the
lakers but i know the lakers might be
worried about 30
in the playoff game but uh i mean in a
play-in game
but with that being said uh aaron
what is your take the comments are
coming in but what is your take on the
playing game
i like the playing games i mean i think
this gives an incentive for teams to
avoid tanking
obviously makes it more competitive i
just feel like it's really convenient
for lebron to come out and say these
comments as of course
they have that number seven seed right
now in the western conference standing
so they don't want to play in that
playing round
but at this rate looks like they might
have to i just think had he come out and
said that from the beginning
i would respect it but now obviously
very controversial since he might be
playing in that tournament
aaron i love the playing tournament as
well i'm right there with you i i like
charlotte to make the playoffs mostly
because
boston is missing a huge piece of their
team in in jalen brown
lamello ball has been playing amazing
terry rozier is like the most
not the most he's in the top i'd say top
10
most underrated and underappreciated
players in the nba
his clutch his clutch numbers are just
gross scary
and scary terry playing against his old
team boston i'm there for that giant
piece
giant giant like container of popcorn
and an additional bag of doritos
because i'm just going to get fat on my
couch watching that if that happens in
the planet scenario
um so yeah i i love it and i like uh
charlotte hornets i believe it was a
plus 124 on the board
uh g-money which playoff team are you
seeing the most gifts of in the comments
and then um
and which team are you looking at to get
in
uh cabbie i see a lot of uh
i i see a lot of no's for the playing
game i also see the warriors in the
comments obviously i mean
the warrior uh i see the lakers in the
comments as well see lakers
oh no they're already in but yeah i
don't know why the lakers in the
comments
set out to make the playoffs i mean they
could lose against the warriors
and then potentially lose against the
winner of the grizzlies and the spurs so
there's a chance if they lose two games
it's a wrap for
ron a.d and company so so i'm gonna give
i'm gonna give that person the hoodie
then okay uh
kennerize ken and racy 98 shout out to
you you're walking over hoodie
i got loft burn sand now no playing game
bye what a what a gift uh shout out to
you you're walking away with a hoodie
uh classic man steven says yep a better
teams deserve to be in the east playoffs
than the celtics man shout out to you
classic steven
uh k-pots cabbie k-pots is coming out of
nowhere with the charlotte hornets gift
let's go
uh you mentioned you mentioned that is
that with lance stevenson
charlotte hornets gif that was lance
that was live
that was led to make him dance now that
was lance
uh my my take is the warriors man i said
it last week aaron and i know
you're new to the show but one thing i
don't like to really switch up my bets
last week they were plus money
this week they're minus 110. if you were
on the train last week you would have to
plus money but just come on
come on hop on the train now it is okay
take the minus 110 i'm telling you guys
what the lock is uh hey i want to see
braun vs 30 in this play in the game man
cubby
because i really feel i really feel
brian don't want those problems brian
don't want those problems
team step team brian in the comments
right now just we just need some
different vibes
team step team braun in the comments
right now uh aaron
sorry we didn't get your pick what which
team are you were on washington last
year
yeah i'm still sticking with washington
i know we had said it last week it was
plus 184 it already moved down to plus
124 it actually went off the board
for a couple days and went back up so
obviously we know that bradley beal kind
of nursing a hamstring strain right now
he's going to be out for tomorrow's game
as well but i think as long as he's
healthy
him and russell westbrook i mean you
know he stole the show last night
i think they're a great duo and i think
they can get it done and obviously this
is a knock at your warriors here i just
wouldn't want to bet them
should they actually have to play lebron
james and lakers team
obviously in this play in tournament
okay but aaron now that russell
westbrook has
has set the record for the most career
triple doubles
how do you think he's going to perform
now like this it's like that huge burden
i feel like
that that exactly has been reached
i mean honestly even betting into that
market it's minus 400
at least yesterday was russell westwork
to have a triple double so it's not even
great value in betting on it i just
think eventually it's gonna
come to a point like he has this record
he was chasing it so maybe over the next
couple games but i could
absolutely be wrong he's gonna have to
step up tomorrow because of course
washington
needs those wins to make sure they stay
in that number 10 seen the eastern
conference standings but overall
it could continue but it's not great
value when betting it at this point
got you oh so you have faith in uh in
the brody
yes brody yeah okay well um
i know that last week you had faith in
the other brody who's next to you
uh but uh g-money
it was a disaster
it was uh doo-doo pie his attempt at a
same-game parlay as offered by fanduel
uh can we please
look at the ticket and then g-money we'd
like to give you 15 seconds to explain
yourself
oh my goodness that's so much fun but so
many uh
x's is that a treasure map i mean
0 for 5. hey hey hey hey hey we had a
bad day what did what is big
what happened it happens it happens yeah
thank you aaron it is something that's
gonna support here in the group chat
last week no no we're alive last week i
took a l
and tonight i bounced back is is the big
sean line but
bro like you haven't gone over five ever
i don't think unless we're talking about
your collegiate baseball career ever
ever
ever not even in baseball now i don't
even think i ever went 0-5 i'm sure
positive you're bound to bounce back
though
you got to get just all it takes you you
you see the good vibes right there
that's coming through the sunset is
about
through the streams yeah shout out to
you aaron see cabbie
take a take a page out of her book homie
bring in all type of goodbyes hey bring
some better vibes
same game parlay my dude come on i got
you bro all right i got you i got you
look at here
what game you guys do not know hey if
you guys do not know you know i i
this special special group of people
it's my squad uh the winners-only squad
uh i had to tap in with a head honcho
man i had to tap in with a head hound so
didn't have a good week last week but
that is okay like big sean say
we bounce back and this week we are
bouncing back with dodgers
mad dodgers uh he's helped me with this
same game parlay shout out to my guy
matt dodger
let's get it started man let's get it
started starting it off with duncan
starting it it off with duncan duncan
robinson
go get 10. okay go get 10 duncan
all i need you to do is just go get 10
uh
three threes go get fouled make a make
up make up make a free throw
maybe two make it easy and then uh call
it a day but duncan go get 10.
moving on cabbie this is you i i told
him hey we need a canadian connection
with cabbie
he's like i got you g tristan thompson
salute salute tt there would be no
tristan thompson old slender
go get nine and a half rebounds go get
nine and now
go get ten eleven twelve maybe thirteen
you know make it make us feel good about
it so yeah we're taking the over we're
taking
we're taking the over in his rebound
total moving on jason tatum
we just got the unfortunate news with my
guy jaylen brown going down for the year
that is okay tatum realizes that the
game
that the team must be on his back he's
putting the team on his back and it's
starting
tonight knee 30 jason
need 30. uh moving on bam
bam out of bio b plus she likes to grab
those rebounds no no
okay simmer down there cabbage lots of
oats some are down there
yeah hey yeah you know that he's like uh
he's a playmaker now right like he does
he does play
center technically but my guys loves to
pass the rock and
loves to shoot it at a game winner a
couple weeks ago
this eight and a half if if tristan
thompson is getting you 10 rebounds
that's that's eating into the share of
the pie that ban
and there's time lord god
bam bam like he he usually grabs at
least like a couple offensive rebounds
just off putbacks he puts it up gets it
back puts it up gets it back
i mean come on just do that maybe two
three times we're at six
then go he's a big man go grab three and
we're there
that's that's the trade that's the
that's the one that might get you uh
that might be another
red x on the on the ticket what else you
got closing another
another bat bad vibe from cabbie it's
okay we're getting used to it
anyway jimmy butler jimmy butler give me
buckets jimmy buckets i like it i'll get
your stops go give me seven go give me
seven assists
yes go give me over six and a half
assists jimmy that's what you do go be a
playmaker go throw the ball to bam
a couple alley oops find duncan maybe
goran
you know tyler go be a playmaker jimmy
but that's it right there pull up the
ticket i like it i feel like i want to
go
please bet this right now wow oh thank
three to one
that is impressive okay this is a this
is a legitimate i love all players right
here
t-money yeah this is this is a legit
ticket
aaron what do you oh so now do you have
any thoughts on any particular like
whoa well i just my main point is just
obviously last week there was none of
them hitting in that parlay
but it was more the fun ones but overall
i just feel like
this is so fun because it's player props
this is a great one you got to do player
props with the same game parlays on
fanduel that's the most fun
it is the most fun okay so uh g money
good luck sir
uh good luck um before we go this is our
last show before
uh the regular season um ends and we
kick off the playoffs
the the play-in tournament goes from may
18th to may 21st
so um it's been a long season with a
bunch of twists and turns
uh so i'm asking the question what team
or player has cost you the most
money this season greg we know there's a
loyal audience that
that our loyal group of followers
whether it's the winners only
or people that tap into the show every
week they appear in the comments
um how transparent are they gonna be in
admitting which team or player cost them
the most amount of money because that's
what we need right now we need
transparency
and we need people to admit who cost
them money
cabbie yeah let me ask them let me ask
them hey people in the audience i need
gifts
give me gifts gifts of a specific player
a team or a player i'm gonna add i'm
gonna add specific gifts
of a team or a player let me say it one
more time
specific gifts of a team or player uh
you guys fill them comments up let me
know who lost you the most money this
year
who lost y'all the most money this year
fill them comments up let us know
aaron gabby yeah so who who is it for
you aaron yeah um
yes the celtics their player props
absolutely screwed me at the beginning
of the season tatum brown walker i
didn't know which one was gonna take the
lead
on which night and i kept betting it and
i kept losing another team i
hated betting on i refuse because when i
get in this mood where
i'm done with the team i'm done with
them so the celtics player props are
crossed off also the milwaukee bucks
inconsistent against the thread i hate
taking them
i talk trash about them almost every
morning on my morning show because i
can't stand them i get it
during that number three spot right now
in the eastern conference standings but
doesn't mean
they are good when betting them oh my
goodness the box
like this is the first time we've ever
had buck slander on the group chat
the other what did the greek god ever do
to you oh i can go in
yeah you don't want to get me started
you probably won't end well
yeah this is this is a safe space you're
welcome to throw slander to
anybody except uh tristan thompson um
i uh i've been bit by chasing in late
games
i've learned from uh the great kelly
stewart who said
don't chase bad money with good money i
did not follow that advice
so i ended up losing so much money with
the lakers and the golden state warriors
i love live betting games and player
props
it was the player props that got me just
like aaron you said the celtics
was the squad that that nipped you in
the butt with player props
i was you know it was it was three point
overs
whether it was jta or or or kelly ubre
junior
a couple times i bet on two-way wiggins
andrew wiggins and i
they didn't come through it was when i
look back at like
at my the results in the the history of
my
that it was i saw a lot of golden state
warriors so the warriors that
are the squad that that cost me the most
money uh g-money who's the most
expensive player this year according to
the audience
and according to your fanduel account
cabbie yes sir i am in the comments i'm
in the comments right here on the handy
dandy ipad i got champ cheese
he gave us a gif of young thug you know
young thug is from atlanta so
i'm connecting the dots here going to
connect the dots he's talking about the
atlanta hawks shout out to you champ
cheese
you are walking away with a hoodie uh i
see a lot of
celtics see a lot of celtics i got omar
lobo 49
rocking with the bulls gave us a gift
right here
uh andy lam andy lam 805 fastest letdown
beginning of the year talking about the
miami heat
you see tyler hero right there tyler
hero in the miami yeah
uh andy lam fortunately sorry
you uh tonga
gong ho tonga gongo got the uh the new
orleans pelicans
new orleans pelicans and zion new
orleans pelicans and zion
he put up a gift right there uh shout
out to everybody that was mentioned
shout out about you
buddy uh do you even bet
again we invented that that tournament
because of you the worst bettors of all
time and it was
it's because of ug money the better the
better that doesn't actually bet
that's you cabbie i bet
i i bet and and everyone knows that i've
been everybody that interacts with let's
see sometimes
let's see your phone uh
yeah exactly i mean you can get my phone
not gonna show us your phone
we can see we can see we can see my
phone i i mean
anyway the real ones know that i bet uh
i like man cabbie you threw me off what
squad man
team it's kind of the most i bet
oh oh yeah we're doing we're doing this
one all right so yeah it's this it's
this squad man like
they mean a lot to me um they always
have my back
and i always have their back um
and this squad's name is uh
winners only what wait you're
you're blaming your losses on the
audience
no no no no no no no losses no losses
winner winners only that's that's that's
the motto that's the brand
and that's what we're gonna do winners
only if i had to pick a team if i had to
pick a team i'll pick the warriors i'll
be honest
they they let me down this year i mean
but i kind of knew that but i'm
you know i rock with my team i bet i bet
some money on them they lost me they
lost me money but other than that
other than that winners only and please
say the police
i don't want to watch my team lose and
also lose me money at the same time i
feel like that's the worst feeling
so i feel like i actually stay away from
my team so i'm betting sometimes
that's a heady play aaron well done
that's a good nugget
that's a great nugget there yeah hey
listen uh thank you to everybody for
tapping into the group chat this week
presented by fanduel remember what you
learned today the playing tournament
starts on may 18th and it goes to may
21st so there's still time
to lock in some bets on which team you
think will make the playoffs
the the group chat uh the chat continues
live
24 7 in the bleacher report app under
the sports betting stream in the
the community stream and we're back on
tuesday
next week to kick off the playoffs
alongside
aaron dolan from fanduel and greg ivory
my name is cabbie richters and we are
leaving the group chat thanks
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign